cette semaine ce centre culturel russe a
été vandalisé à plusieurs reprises cette
fois ci le directeur a appelé la police
pour signaler ces graffitis rouge sang à
l'entrée du bâtiment il est impossible
ne pas remarquer c'est donc ouvrez un
historien du russe depuis le début de la
guerre en ukraine les membres de la
communauté russe de paris témoigne aussi
d'insultés de nombreux amalgames comme
cette étudiante qui a préféré rester
anonyme j'étais chien 2005 français et
je lui ai donné la carte vitale et l'a
vu que je suis russe il m'a demandé tu
es content que ce que tu as fait
qu'est ce que t'en plus d'un an a fait
dans sa librairie natalia turine elle
choisit d'afficher en vitrine sa
solidarité envers le peuple ukrainien et
dans les rayons les livres sur l'ukraine
sont disposés bien en évidence ceux qui
ont un peu de coeur évidemment ils
vivent mal après le problème ce qu' ils
sont pas plus malheureux que ceux qui
sont sous la bombe 1 et 2 ils sont quand
même bien mieux que ceux qui sont à
moscou et qui risque risque 15 ans de
prison pour pour dire une phrase de
travers donc on n'est vraiment pas à
plaindre nous les russes à paris
la surveillance a été renforcée autour
de certains endroits fréquentés par la
communauté russe comme la cathédrale de
la sainte-trinité ou le conservatoire
rachmaninoff qui aurait reçu des menaces
de mort